bonsoir et bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 l'actu sur TV film Le
Journal de la rédaction au cours du
prochain quart d'heure portrait de la
nouvelle Miss Yvelines originaire de
Guyancourt en sport les Templiers qui
réalisent une excellente entrée en
matière en Coupe d'Europe c'est du foot
US et puis l'invité de ce soir à Karine
mcgrat elle est la responsable des
archives au château de Versailles le
château et qui présente actuellement une
série sur Internet autour de la grande
guerre nous en parlons dans quelques
instants Pâques la fête la plus
importante de la chrétienté mais aussi
moment au combien important pour les
amateurs de chocolat les Français en
consomme en moyenne plus de 6 kilos et
demi par an selon le syndicat du
chocolat 5% des ventes se déroulent
pendant ce fameux week-end prolongé de
fin avril seulement les Français ne sont
pas les cela apprécier le chocolat
l'attrait des pays émergents pour ces
douceurs menacent d’ailleurs la
production
chaque année les clients sont au
rendez-vous paquet ces fameux chocolat
dans cette boutique de Versailles les
vendeurs s'activent
est-ce que ça vous va très bien alors
21 44 je voudrais un une vingtaine
d'euros pour certains un peu plus pour
d'autres à chacun son budget pour les
chocolats de Pâques
sa tante à 70 euros
voilà c'est pour la décoration de la
table un budget que ces consommateurs
devront peut-être bientôt revoir à la
baisse de plus en plus prisé à travers
le monde à long terme le cacao viendrait
à manquer le chocolat deviendra-t-il un
produit de luxe la demande est beaucoup
plus importante qu'elle l'était
auparavant et si comme ça le devient la
Chine l'Inde je commence à à manger du
chocolat
là le problème se posera il n'y aura pas
assez de cacao de produits résultat les
cours du cacao flambe et cette hausse
pourrait être répercutée sur les prix du
chocolat à la vente certains versaillés
affirment faire déjà les frais mais la
gourmandise est plus forte je me fais
quand même une raison je me prive sur
d'autres choses et pas sur le chocolat
Nigéria et la Côte d'Ivoire qui détient
à elle seule 40% du marché mondial
on reste à Versailles mais on ne va pas
parler de chocolat on va parler histoire
l'invité de ce 22 avril c'est Karine
magrad bonsoir bienvenue sur ce plateau
vous êtes la chef du service des
archives au château donc de Versailles
venu ce soir nous reparler des richesses
sur lesquelles vous veillez mais aussi
la manière de les mettre en valeur comme
cette web série sur la Grande Guerre 4
mini films composés inédite diffusé
chaque semaine quasiment jusqu'à la fin
du mois de juin en tout cas sur Internet
qui retrace la vie au château de 14 de
1914 à 1918 premier épisode déjà
disponible et gratuitement bien sûr sur
votre site internet depuis le début du
mois pourquoi le choix de cette web
série déjà de ce format là qui est assez
rare
alors ça s'inscrit dans une politique
d'ensemble du château qui produit des
reportages réguliers sur l'histoire du
château ou les restaurations qui ont qui
ont cours au château alors sur la
web-série on voit quelques images
justement de quel type d'archives vous
disposez il y a pas uniquement des
archives de du château qui sont qui ont
été utilisés non tout à fait c'est un
partenariat avec la Bibliothèque
nationale qui dispose d'un fond
photographique très important et puis
également des photographies qui sont
prises dans les agences de presse ou
également le ministère de la Défense
l'armée et toute une mise en scène c'est
très forcément intéressant on rentre
tout de suite dans le sujet cette
informat très court donc forcément on
regarde du début à la fin d'une traite
on parle beaucoup forcément quand on
parle d'histoire de la signature dans la
galerie des Glaces du traité de la paix
le traité de Versailles le 28 juin 1919
mais qu'apprend-t-on qu'est-ce qu'on a
encore à découvrir sur la vie au château
entre 1914 et 1918 la vie a continué au
château alors la vie a continué et nous
apprenons ce sont des choses tout à fait
nouvelles puisqu'en fait c'est une
histoire qui n'a pas intéressé jusqu'à
présent il fallait attendre le
centenaire pour pouvoir s'intéresser à
ce qui s'est passé à Versailles pendant
la Première Guerre mondiale et donc par
exemple des tranchées qui ont été faites
dans le parc ou un parc de
ravitaillement des bêtes accords qui
étaient disposés qui étaient installés
jusqu'au Grand Canal donc ce sont des
visages de Versailles qui sont tout à
fait inédits et exceptionnels le château
était fermé au public on a surtout voulu
aussi préserver les oeuvres voire même
les cacher on imaginant éventuellement
le pire alors le musée a été fermé
temporairement il a réouvert dès l'année
1915 lorsque le front s'est stabilisé à
l'est de la France et il était ouvert
néanmoins partiellement donc on avait
accès à certaines salles du musée et on
a effectivement protégé les oeuvres au
début et à la fin de la guerre ça donne
lieu à des images qui sont vraiment
surprenantes par exemple les sculptures
du parc qui sont sous des abris fait de
plâtre et de et de bois ces documents
vous les avez retrouvés il y a longtemps
ils étaient où jusqu'à présent il était
stockés juste uniquement accessible pour
les chercheurs alors ces documents
étaient pour ce qui concerne nos
archives ils sont restés au château et
ils étaient jusqu'à une dizaine d'années
dans les services qui les avaient
produits donc en fait les les
fonctionnaires
confient à leurs archives aux
successeurs et on a créé un service
d'archives qui maintenance centralise
tous ces documents et assure la
conservation et également l'ouverture au
public effectivement on laisse un peu
cette web sérieuse de côté pour voir
quels sont les types de documents dont
vous disposez aux archives c'est très
riche il y a beaucoup de choses alors
c'est très riche c'est il y a certains
volumes déjà
on conserve 2 km et demi de d'archives
si on met bout à bout toutes les boîtes
et toutes les conserver au château c'est
conservé à la grande écurie et bientôt
au grand commun donc
ou tous les services sont rassemblés
et on dispose de trésors effectivement
sur l'histoire des du 19e et du 20e
siècle quel type de document alors à la
fois des plans d'architecture qui
montrent par exemple les aménagements de
Louis-Philippe qui a transformé le
palais en musée donc ce sont des
documents vraiment exceptionnels et qui
ont une valeur historique et
patrimoniale de premier ordre et puis
des fonds photographiques par exemple
aussi qui sont qui sont très très beaux
et très riches tous les documents ont
été exploités déjà où il y a encore des
choses à découvrir à analyser il y a des
choses encore à découvrir et ça nous
arrive encore
de temps en temps de trouver des pépites
justement combien de personnes
travaillent et comment vous travaillez
quelle est la journée type de chercheurs
d'un archiviste d'un restaurant en tout
cas votre travail peut-être aussi au
quotidien alors nous sommes une équipe
de quatre personnes
donc le travail est très varié puisqu'en
fait cela va depuis collecte des
archives puisqu'on a à la fois des fonds
historiques et également des on est
amené à conserver les archives actuelles
également les archives informatiques par
exemple est-ce qu'on produit encore
forcément chaque jour de nouvelles
archives pour plus tard bien sûr les
archives de demain sont produites
aujourd'hui donc il faut il faut les
prendre en compte dès maintenant et puis
la journée type c'est très variable
vraiment et ça on est amené à recevoir
des chercheurs ou des services de
l'établissement aussi du château qui qui
ont besoin des archives pour leurs
activités ponctuellement le public aussi
peut y accéder autrement que par les
publications que vous pouvez faire comme
la web-série dont on parlait tout à
l'heure alors les archives sont enfin
dans la mesure où le château produit des
archives publics elles sont ouvertes à
tous citoyen qui en fait la demande au
même titre que les archives municipales
ou départementales
cependant il faut tout de même avoir un
peu une expérience de la recherche et
puis avoir un sujet évidemment qui
justifie de venir mais sinon on peut on
accueille également des petits groupes
par exemple exemple et ceux qui ont une
carte d'abonnement pour visiter le
château viennent de temps en temps pour
une petite explication autour de
documents et un voyage dans l'histoire
de Versailles prochain chantier après la
Grande Guerre et encore les trois à
trois épisodes de la web-série à
produire d'ici la fin du mois de juin
les prochains chantiers
écoutez on verra ça va vraiment on
travaille sur du moyen terme il y avait
cette guerre qui qu'on a essayé enfin
qu'on essaye un petit peu de mettre en
valeur enfin et puis de faire connaître
à l'occasion du centenaire évidemment de
cette seconde guerre 14-18 cette
websérie qui est diffusée gratuitement
sur le site internet du château de
Versailles le premier épisode qui est
déjà en ligne depuis le début du mois
ils le seront régulièrement jusqu'au 28
juin a priori la date donc commémorative
du de la signature du traité de paix à
Versailles merci encore d'être venu nous
parler de cette initiative en plateau
Flora Coquerel Miss France 2014 était
présente ce week-end dans toute autre
sujet à présent lors de l'élection de
Missy blind c'était au centre commercial
à plaisir et c'est Mégane mend y une
guyancourtoise qui a récupéré la
précieuse écharpe donc de Miss Yvelines
elle va représenter le département au
concours de Miss Île-de-France est un
contournable avant d'espérer pourquoi
pas monter sur le podium national Ker
Cambier
le temps d'une après-midi la galerie
commerciale de plaisir s'est transformée
en podium ces jeunes filles qui défilent
tentent de décrocher le titre de Miss
Yvelines une première étape vers le
titre de Miss France au programme de
passage pour tenter de convaincre le
jury le premier en tenu de soirée
et des yeux qui pétillent c'est ça
l'effet Miss France parmi les candidates
Mégane 20 ans deuxième dauphine
Île-de-France l'année dernière retente
sa chance aujourd'hui pour aller encore
plus loin mais sa première expérience ne
lui a pas retiré toute appréhension
c'est un peu soulagé aussi mais un peu
stressé des résultats mais je suis
contente de l'avoir fait et même si j'ai
pas gagné bah ça restera une bonne
expérience donc je suis contente parmi
les critères de sélection les deux
défilés bien sûr après la tenue de
soirée le maillot de bain mais aussi la
présentation orale le visage et la tenue
générale et la concurrence est rude
chaque année le nombre de candidats
grossit on a la chance en Île-de-France
de regrouper 8 départements donc
l'appel à candidature est beaucoup plus
fournie évidemment et aujourd'hui on
peut compter on a compté environ 230
candidatures pour l'Île-de-France donc
c'est énorme
en arène de l'événement la missile de
France 2013 et bien sûr l'actuel Miss
France chargé des polycandidates oui ça
rappelle toujours des souvenirs parce
que voir les candidats voir les choses
le stress qui monte et voir se dire
est-ce que ça va marcher ou pas dans des
discours un petit peu bégayés de ne pas
savoir quoi dire c'est vrai que c'est
dans la pelle des souvenirs à toutes
parce que on passe tout par là et on
commence tout par là et peut-être que la
future Miss France est par mienne on ne
sait pas on verra
méga Mendy décroche finalement le titre
de Miss Yveline et avec lui sa place
pour l'élection de missiles de France en
septembre prochain
on passe au sport 4 ans après leur
dernière participation les Templiers
d'Élancourt retrouver la Coupe d'Europe
de football américain pour ce premier
match de poule un adversaire de poids le
quintuple champion du Royaume-Uni les
blitz de Londres mais à l'arrivée une
excellente c'est le cas de le dire vous
allez le voir surprise pour les locaux
Anthony Rech
il l'avait annoncé en début de saison
les Templiers veulent tout gagner cette
année et un titre européen passé par une
victoire face au blitz de Londres
compact Élancourt débloque rapidement le
compteur 3-0 après ce coup de pied de
Cyril Gérard
mais la défense se fait surprendre
quelques minutes plus tard sur cette
passe de Joe Thomson pour Charlie Joseph
d'assignation voilà qui est resté très
calme dans sa poche il a vu que ça
arrivait mais il a attendu s'il est
Templiers réagissent par Jérémy Laroque
et même 10 à 7 dans ce premier acte il
semble paralysé par l'enjeu en face le
jeu londonien est varié bien en place
rien ne semble pouvoir enrayer la
machine orchestrée par Joe Thompson et
alors qu'il reste 5 secondes de jeu dans
cette première période les Blitz frappe
à nouveau attention Thomson
de toute façon il va jouer non non but
sur le 10 au belle défense oh là là là
là là
il a réussi à la récupérer superbe touch
down c'est magnifique on pouvait s'y
attendre qu'il allait jouer sur le 10
l'homme a tout faire de cette équipe
Jack dayley permet au lottonien de mener
14 à 10 à la pause
on a fait des fautes en interne au début
on a essayé de la commencer très
doucement lentement avec monter en mais
c'est pas le jeu qu'il fallait donc on
va tout de suite installer notre force
on a sorti le receveur ce qui est
vraiment la force templier au retour des
vestiaires les joueurs d'Emmanuel
Charest semble transformer et c'est
receveurs Super Sonic vont sortir du
bois à commencer par Anthony Couvin sur
cette passe courte de sunshelton
l'international français va flirter avec
la touche sur 40 yards les défenseurs
londonien ne verront que ces crampons
terminé et voilà ça c'est Anthony
les Templiers repassent devant 17 14 au
Royaume-Uni le championnat élite n'a pas
encore débuté et cela se voit au fil des
minutes physiquement le glitch se sombre
les Londoniens laissent des boules va en
receveur et l'on courtois il n'en
fallait pas plus pour la mobylette
Anthony Couvin Showtime va justifier son
surnom à trois reprises et inscrire un
quadruplé à lui seul il terrasse le
Blitz et permettent aux Templiers de
rester invaincu à domicile en face de
poules européennes et pour finir le
travail sont compères Jérémy Laroque
réceptionnera une dernière passe de
sanchelton c'était l'objectif j'avais
dit c'est non seulement la victoire mais
surtout une victoire large puisque dans
cette formule il y a des adversaires
qu'on rencontre pas ça va jouer au
galavera donc il faut absolument qu'on
gagne les matchs mais avec des gros
écarts les Templiers s'imposent
finalement 51 à 14 ils assomme le
quintuple champion du Royaume-Uni et
surtout on voit un message clair à toute
l'Europe du foot US
une dernière information avant de se
quitter importante opération de
nettoyage de la colline d'Élancourt
anciennement colline de la revanche est
prévu le 23 mai prochain de 13h à 17h
organisé par les services de la
Communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin et les étudiants de
l'Institut supérieur de l'environnement
les étudiants qui recherchent d'ores et
déjà des bénévoles pour les aider
inscriptions sur le site internet de la
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin merci de nous avoir suivi
ce journal est maintenant terminé vous
pouvez bien évidemment le consulter sur
notre site internet excellente soirée et
à demain mercredi pour une nouvelle
édition